[Musique]
emmanuel macron s'est entretenue pendant
une heure avec une poignée d'anciens de
whirlpool je me suis fait avoir avec
vous leur a confié emmanuel macron nous
allons devoir emprunter de 160 milliards
d'euros pour passer la nuit et 2022 donc
il ya un problème de responsabilité me
semble t'il dans ce budget je pense que
au sénat nous ne voterons pas un budget
en dans un tel déséquilibre puisque vous
êtes autorité sur les transports en
particulier sur le ferroviaire est ce
qu'à des sujets que vous voulez rajouter
au
c'est des sujets trop important pour le
quotidien que pour fois que vous ayez
droit à la parole et apporter les sujets
qui sont
en fait c'est maintenant l'idée de
recréer un service de six mois
obligatoire que j'ai appelé service
militaire de sécurité de protection
civile et que minutes plus tard macro
fait alors référence à son passé de
ministre c'est pas une prime la prime
ségur c'est une augmentation de salaire
et plusieurs ici ont eu des
responsabilités dans le domaine de la
santé c'est quel âge entre 18 et 21 ans
mais un soir et filles tout le monde
vers son effigie je pense qu'il ya
besoin de recréer ce lien pour l'unité
de notre pays une réunion d'urgence
s'est tenue ce matin au ministère de
l'intérieur autour de gérald darmanin et
de la ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu avec les instances du
football français dans la perspective de
15 jours c'est comme extrêmement rapide
pour pouvoir très rapidement évacué la
minorité agissante qui polluent
évidemment le beau spectacle six mois de
prison avec sursis et cinq ans
d'interdiction de stade de l'olympique
lyonnais la peine prononcée contre
l'homme de 32 ans qui a jeté une
bouteille d'eau sur dimitri payet and
the state of
mind cela
vient d'évoquer la guadeloupe il était
absolument évident qu'on allait au
devant d'un incident c'est au poids que
je me demande si d'aucuns ont pas eu
l'idée d'organiser un bras de fer pour
prouver leur autorité et la vraie
question c'est est-ce que le vaccin peut
empêcher la circulation du virus je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la réponse est non
donc à quoi sert le pass sanitaire
quelques symptômes dont une légère tout
pour jean castex qu'à contacter après
que sa fille de 11 ans a été
diagnostiquée positive au co vide le
premier ministre s'est astreint à
l'isolément lorsqu'on est ministre on
croise parfois beaucoup plus de gens et
donc mathématiquement on augmente le
nombre de chances cette malade un double
vaccinés qui alco vide comme monsieur
castex et qui sert des mains est
beaucoup plus d'eux dangereux ce matin
c'est la cible castex il est clair que
dans l'esprit de beaucoup chez chacun de
nos concitoyens en hexagone comme en
outre mer il y avait ce côté le co vide
est derrière nous on voit bien
malheureusement qui sera plein hier
matin jean castex se rencontraient à
bruxelles son homologue belge alexandre
de croo il était notamment accompagné de
quatre ministres florence parly gérald
darmanin eric dupond moretti et clément
bonne dix ministres sont qu'à contacter
ce n'est pas votre cas non si je ne
serais pas devant vous également vous
être négatif tout va bien jusqu'ici tout
va bien mais vous êtes masqué et nous
aussi je vois vous êtes venus masquer
votre test négatif hier soir j'avais été
renommé love note positive vous n'êtes
pas qu'à contacter pour ma part je ne
suis pas qu'à contacter jean castex
était également en indre-et-loire
présenter un plan pour relancer le
tourisme
mais depuis il n'a effectué aucun autre
déplacement officiel voici tous les cas
contact pendant cette visite
[Musique]
kulda tonique au vide il s'est au cap
vert le commis
davantage un nom à l'isolément